Abdullahb.
He narrates
an incident that occurred in the time
of the prophet sallall.aii wasam
on the heels of the battle of Hunain. As
we mentioned before, the battle of
Hunain
was a battle that took place only a few
weeks after the conquest of Mecca.
Now why is that important? Why is that
relevant to our story? This is very
relevant because
of all the battles which the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam attended. The
battle of Hunain is probably the battle
which there were most new Muslims
attending with the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam.
The army was filled with people that had
accepted Islam
after the conquest of Mecca. So they
had waited to accept Islam until they
almost had no other choice. And I say
almost because they
wanted to hold out on accepting Islam.
And many of them the only reason they
were holding out was just stubbornness
and arrogance. There was no other
reason. Islam had become incredibly
common place in the Arab Peninsula at
this time. Most of the tribes have moved
towards accepting Islam and following
Islam, accepting the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam. Many companions had accepted
Islam prior to the conquest of Mecca
including
and many of the elder
chieftains in Mecca had held out to
the last minute. So when the prophet
sallallah.aii wasallam came and Mecca
then became the house of Allah that was
overseen by the Muslim the idols were
removed. it was announced that the
next year so the conquest of Mecca took
place in the seventh year. Some
historians place it in the eighth year
after Hijra.
When it took place in the month of
Ramadan, there were still people that
may have been traveling to come for Hajj
that year of the next following years
only 3 months. And so the prophet
sallall.aii alaihi wasallam did not make
Hajj that year because there would be a
huge mixture of mushik
that were still coming and they were on
their way and they had not accepted
Islam and they did a lot of indecent
things when they came for Hajj some of
them made in the nude there was a lot
of idolatry many pagans were were
coming to attend into the hedge season.
And so it was too late to stop them at
that point because they had not heard
and two or 3 months at that time was not
enough time for the news to spread that
Mecca is now part of the Muslim and
the Muslim state. And so the prophet
sallallah.aii wasallam held off making
Hajj immediately. He did not make Hajj
that year. He waited and he sent Abu
Bakr to make Hajj and he took with him.
And that is when the announcement was
made during Hajj of the opening verses
of.
And so it was announced to everyone that
this is the final year that
idolattors will be allowed near the Kaa.
This is it. Anyone who wants to return
in the following year or subsequent
years, you must accept Islam. It is only
for the Muslim. Now this is the house of
Allah. No more u idolatry will be
accepted. And then they also disallowed
a lot of other things such as making B
in the nude and all of these things
these indeencies and these beliefs and
superstitions
that went along with Hajj in the time
of Jah. So that was right after the
conquest of Mecca which is why the
prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam made
Hajj in the ninth year after Hijra in
the ninth year after Hijra which was his
last year and he passed away a few
months afteratam.
So the battle of
took place right after the conquest of
Mecca all of those new Muslims some of
the Arab tribes that were begrudging
begrudgingly attending at the time. So a
lot of mistakes were made during the
battle of Hanimain. And so of these
kinds of unsavory characters that were
with the Muslim army during the battle
of Hunain is this man here that we're
going to read about in this incident
who says
faith
[Silence]
and and sobb says after the battle of
the messenger of Allaham
gave of his
portion this was not of The the
unfell that is what is divided into
five portions. 1/5if is to muslim. The
other four fifths of the spoils of war.
Whatever is on the battlefield at that
point that is distributed amongst the
troops and the soldiers as Allah has
mentioned and decided. This is different
than what the prophet is distributing
here in this narration. He distributed
all of the
Now comes al what is al fate? Al fate is
what is given to the leader or
traditionally at that time was given to
the general of a military that had won
on the battlefield
from the village or from the state that
was conquered. So it will be things like
land
houses, it will be things like
livestock etc. Traditionally in Arab
culture at that time all of it went to
the general. All of it. It was
considered to be his alone and he would
either keep it or give it to his
minions. However, the fate was
distributed and used by the prophet
sallall.aii alaihi wasallam as an
incentive
to bring tribe leaders into Islam or
to keep them in Islam. People who had
only accepted Islam because the Muslims
were winning. That's the only reason
they accepted Islam. And so a person who
comes only for that reason, that tribe
leader has hundreds, thousands of people
standing behind him that are watching to
see what the tribe leader is doing. If
he accepts Islam, they will all accept
Islam. If he leads leaves Islam, they
will all leave Islam. If he fights
against the Muslim, they will all fight
to the death with him against the
Muslim. And so it becomes very important
to incentivize these tribe leaders to
remain Muslim. And Allah has even given
a portion of zaka
to a non-Muslim
in order to incentivize
non-Muslims to be reasonable with the
Muslim as Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
mentions in TBA. So this fate is
completely to the prophet's discretion
even by standards. He can give it to
whomever he chooses.
wasam. He didn't keep it for himself and
he didn't give it to his closest
companions. Who did he give it to? He
started to give to some tribe leaders
like
and
apostated from Islam after the prophet's
death to show you how unstable these
people's Islam was at the time. He
apostated and he joined a man who
claimed to be a prophet and a messenger
and he fought with him until he was
captured and literally put in a cage
before he entered into Islam a second
time begrudgingly. So these are the
types of people that the prophet
sallallah.aii wasallam gave this fate
to. Now when he distributed it, a man
commented who was upset that he didn't
receive any and he said
he said by Allah this distribution
is not just and it is not Allah Allah's
u Allah Allah's is not sincerity that is
driving this distribution. So he's in he
is accusing the prophet sallall.aii
alaihi wasallam of being unjust and
accusing him of doing things for other
than the sake of Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala which is a a very bold accusation
and this man's name is he was referred
to as
duler
is his actual first name he is
from Benny Zra and he is the father
of the
first innovation in Islam which happened
during the time of the companions
and the were later fought against by
Aliib.
The are the ones responsible. He is the
forefather of those who later ended up
murdering Afan.
later murdering Ali Talib, later causing
the battle that took place between even
some of the companions in the battle of
the camel
and also the battle of Sufi and also
the misunderstanding that took place
between
and
the armies of Hashem. and the armies of
all of this happened because of what?
Because of it started where? It started
with this statement.
Just take a moment to really reflect on
that. All of that bloodshed,
all of that murder, all of that misery,
all of that innovation which is still
present today 1500 years later.
Where did it start? By a man who was
upset that he didn't get what he had his
heart set on of that which is extra. And
so he accused he accused the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam. What was the
innovation?
The innovation was perhaps
even the messenger of Allah at times is
not just
that's the innovation.
The innovation is
a belief that even the messenger of
Allah Muhammad Sam
is
unjust at times and is motivated by
other than Allah. This is an incredible
innovation in Islam. It's the first
innovation and he is considered the
forefather and spiritual father of all
innovation that came after this is
and so
when he said this
said
I
I'm going to tell the messenger of Allah
what you just said.
So I came to the prophet and I told him
what this man had said. The prophet
sallall.aii wasallam got very upset. He
said
[Silence]
we
And so
he
when he heard this, Ib says the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam became so angry
that his face changed and his face got
so red it was a surf which is a a
type of very deep dark maroon red that
they used to dye clothes at the time. So
the prophet Sam
responded and said,
"Who then is left on the earth that's
going to be just if Allah and his
messenger are not just?" Then he said,
"Then the prophet sallall.aii alaihi
wasallam said, "May Allah have mercy
upon MS. He was harmed by his people
more than this, but in spite of that, he
was still patient."
And this narration is collected by both
and Muslim.
Alhamdulillah.
Yeah. Come on.